♪ ♪ ♪
- Viens t'asseoir, viens
t'asseoir.
♪ ♪ ♪
Vas-y doucement... Parfait!
Il est-tu trop droit,
ton dossier?
- Non, c'est correct.
- Ce n'est pas un rendez-vous
comme les autres aujourd'hui
pour Kevin. Il est ici pour
effacer son tatouage.
- Salut! T'es-tu confortable?
Il est-tu assez haut?
- Oui, oui.
- Toi, t'es-tu trop haut?
- Non, c'est pas pire.
- Tu n'as pas le vertige?
On est parti! Bye-bye, poisson!
KEVIN LUSSIER, client
- C'était un ami qui s'est
improvisé tatoueur qui m'a dit :
je pourrais te faire un tatoo.
Fait que, moi, j'étais jeune,
un petit peu naïf aussi.
Je connaissais pas toutes
les procédures, je l'ai
laissé faire.
STÉPHANNY BOSSÉ
artiste tatoueuse
- En ce moment, on est en train
de faire un bras complètement
"blackout". C'est une façon
assez "hardcore" de faire
un "cover".
- Des clients comme lui,
Stéphanie en a de plus en plus.
- On a vraiment vu une hausse
de ce qu'on appelle, nous
autres, en bon jargon
de tatoueurs, des "scratcheurs".
- Sans formation officielle
reconnue, de plus en plus
de gens s'improvisent tatoueurs
en achetant en ligne des kits
pour débutants.
♪ ♪ ♪
Les prix varient, mais,
pour une centaine de dollars,
vous pouvez recevoir
des pistolets à tatouage,
des aiguilles, plusieurs types
d'encres variés, bref,
tout l'équipement nécessaire.
0 Une machine à tatouage
qu'on peut se procurer sur Wish,
on va avoir ça à 15 $.
Une machine professionnelle,
on n'a pas ça en bas de 500 $.
Le fait que le prix est "cheap",
c'est comme si je vous envoie
acheter un kit d'outils
chez Dollarama pour réparer
votre voiture, t'sais,
le résultat va être
malheureusement digne
d'un Dollarama.
JEAN-FRANÇOIS TRUDEL
propriétaire Zen Tattoo Laval
- Moi, personnellement,
je ne toucherais pas à ça,
je ne recommanderais pas
non plus à personne de toucher
à ces produits là, ne sachant
pas qu'est-ce qui se cache
derrière.
All right, Kevin, t'es prêt?
Le phénomène du "cover up"
ne date pas de cette année.
C'est sur qu'avec la pandémie,
on a vu une augmentation.
- Jean-François gère un salon
de tatouage depuis 10 ans.
Il connaît bien cette industrie.
- On n'a pas de législation,
on n'a pas d'ordre professionnel
de tatoueurs. C'est vraiment
un domaine qui s'autorégularise,
mais chacun le fait
personnellement.
- Et ça, c'est dangereux,
selon toi?
- Selon moi, oui.
- La plupart des provinces
canadiennes encadrent
cette profession, mais,
au Québec, ce n'est pas le cas.
Le ministère de la Santé
indique que :
Du côté de Santé Canada,
des lois et règlements
existent : ils sont surtout
reliés à l'utilisation
des encres de tatouage.
Les établissements doivent
s'assurer que le produit
ne présente aucun risque.
♪ ♪ ♪
Mais y-a-t-il assez de normes
entourant le matériel acheté
sur le Web?
- C'est vendu en ligne. Ils ne
peuvent pas avoir de contrôle
là-dessus. Qu'est-ce qui arrive
dans une boîte aux frontières?
Ils ne peuvent pas vérifier
chaque colis.
- Et les dangers, ce sont
les risques d'infection
et de contamination.
Dr DANIEL BAROLET, dermatologue
spécialisé, lasers
- On peut s'infecter avec
un virus, comme l'hépatite par
exemple, si l'aiguille n'est pas
propre. Il peut y avoir
justement une contamination
directement implantée dans
la peau, il peut y avoir
le produit aussi qui est
contaminé qu'on va injecter
à l'intérieur qui est contaminé
par des bactéries, qui est
contaminé par des virus.
- Dr Barolet sait de quoi
il parle : il développe
de nouvelles technologies
au laser pour effacer
les tatouages depuis
des décennies.
- Vraiment, c'est pas de l'encre
est faite pour des humains
qui est vendue parfois sur
les marchés comme ça.
Ils peuvent mettre n'importe
quoi, puis vendre au prix
le plus bas, donc ils vont
prendre de l'encre, comme je
disais tantôt qui provient
d'autres domaines comme
les imprimantes.
- Pour éviter le pire,
les amateurs de tatouage
doivent être bien informés.
- Il y a des tatouages qui sont
tellement maganés qu'on a pas
le choix d'envoyer au laser
et des tatouages qui virent
tellement mal qu'on les envoie
à l'hôpital parce que
les infections sont
trop grandes.
- Selon moi, ce qu'il faudrait
faire, c'est plus d'éducation.
C'est sûr que, si on n'en parle
pas, c'est sûr que là,
il pourrait avoir des dérapa